YOU GO TO JAIL?
MARJORIE, I'LL HAVE TO INTERRUPT
YOU.
THE PRESIDENT WALKING IN NOW.
>> TODAY IS IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE
TO SUGGEST A SOLEMN MOMENT.
TODAY THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES EXPRESSLY TOOK
AWAY THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY DIDN'T LIMIT IT.
THEY SIMPLY TOOK IT AWAY.
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE TO A
RIGHT SO IMPORTANT TO SEE MANY
AMERICANS.
BUT THEY DID IT.
IT'S A SAD DAY FOR THE COURT AND
FOR THE COUNTRY.
50 YEARS AGO ROE v. WADE WAS
DECIDED AND HAS BEEN THE LAW OF
THE LAND SINCE THEN.
THIS LANDMARK CASE PROTECTED A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE, HER
RIGHT TO MAKE INTENSELY PERSONAL
DECISIONS WITH HER DOCTOR FREE
FROM INTERFERENCE OF POLITICS.
IT REAFFIRMED BASIC PRINCIPLES
OF EQUALITY AND WOMEN HAVE THE
POWER TO CONTROL THEIR OWN
DESTINY AND HAVE REINFORCED A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT OF PRIVACY, A
RIGHT OF EACH OF US TO CHOOSE
HOW TO LIVE OUR LIVES.
NOW WITH ROE GONE LET'S BE VERY
CLEAR, THE HEALTH AND LIFE OF
WOMEN IN THIS NATION ARE NOW AT
RISK AS VICE PRESIDENT AND NOW
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
I'VE STUDIED THIS CASE
CAREFULLY.
I'VE OVERSEEN MORE SUPREME COURT
CONFIRMATIONS THAN ANYONE TODAY
WHERE THIS CASE WAS ALWAYS
DISCUSSED.
I BELIEVE ROE v. WADE WAS A
CORRECT DECISION.
AS MATTER OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW AND APPLICATION OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY AND
LIBERTIES IN THE MATTERS OF
FAMILY AND PERSONAL AUTONOMY.
IT WAS A DECISION ON A COMPLEX
MATTER THAT DREW A CAREFUL
BALANCE BETWEEN A WOMAN'S RIGHT
TO CHOOSE EARLY IN HER PREGNANCY
AND THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
REGULATE LATER IN THE PREGNANCY.
A DECISION COULD BROADEN
NATIONAL CONSENSUS.
AND MOST AMERICANS OF FAITH AND
BACKGROUND FOUND ACCEPTABLE THAT
HAD BEEN THE LAW OF THE LAND FOR
MOST OF A LIFETIME OF AMERICANS
TODAY.
AND IT WAS A CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLE UPHELD BY JUSTICES
APPOINTED BY DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS ALIKE.
ROE v. WADE WAS A 7-2 DECISION
WRITTEN BY A JUSTICE, APPOINTED
BY A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT,
RICHARD NIXON.
IN THE FIVE DECADES THAT'S
FOLLOWED ROE v. WADE JUSTICES
APPOINTED BY REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS FROM EISENHOWER,
NIXON AND REAGAN, GEORGE W.
BUSH, WERE AMONG THE JUSTICES
WHO VOTED TO UPHOLD THE
PRINCIPLES SET FORTH IN ROE v.
WADE.
IT WAS THREE JUSTICES NAMED BY
ONE PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP, WHO
WERE THE CORE OF TODAY'S
DECISION TO UPEND THE SCALES OF
JUSTICE AND ELIMINATE A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT FOR WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS DECISION IS
A CULMINATION OF A DELIBERATE
EFFORT OVER DECADES TO UPSET THE
BALANCE OF OUR LAW.
IT'S A REALIZATION OF AN EXTREME
IDEOLOGY AND A TRAGIC ERROR OF
THE SUPREME COURT IN MY VIEW.
THE COURT HAS DONE WHAT IT'S
NEVER DONE BEFORE, EXPRESSLY
TAKE AWAY A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
THAT IS SO FUNDAMENTAL TO SEE
MANY AMERICANS THAT HAD ALREADY
BEEN RECOGNIZED.
THE COURT'S DECISION TO DO SO
WILL HAVE REAL AND IMMEDIATE
CONSEQUENCES.
STATE LAWS BANNING ABORTION ARE
AUTOMATICALLY TAKING EFFECT
TODAY, JEOPARDIZING THE HEALTH
OF MILLIONS OF WOMEN, SOME
WITHOUT EXCEPTIONS.
SO EXTREME THAT WOMEN COULD BE
PUNISHED FOR PROTECTING THEIR
HEALTH.
SO EXTREME THAT WOMEN AND GIRLS
WHO ARE FORCED TO BEAR THEIR
RAPIST'S CHILD, A CHILD OF
CONSEQUENCE -- IT JUST STUNS ME.
SO EXTREME THAT DOCTORS WILL BE
CRIMINALIZED FOR FULFILLING
THEIR DUTY TO CARE.
IMAGINE HAVING -- A YOUNG WOMAN
HAVING TO CARRY A CHILD OF
INCEST -- AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
INCEST WITH NO OPTION?
TOO OFTEN THE CASE THE POOR
WOMEN ARE GOING TO BE HIT THE
HARDEST.
IT'S CRUEL.
IN FACT, THE COURT LAID OUT
STATE LAWS CRIMINALIZING
ABORTION THAT GO BACK TO THE
1800s AS RATIONALE.
THE COURT LITERALLY TAKING
AMERICA BACK 150 YEARS.
IT'S A SAD DAY FOR THE COUNTRY,
IN MY VIEW, BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN
THE FIGHTS OVER.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR AND
UNAMBIGUOUS.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN SECURE A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE, THE
BALANCE THAT EXISTED IS FOR
CONGRESS TO RESTORE THE
PROTECTIONS OF ROE v. WADE AS
FEDERAL LAW.
NO EXECUTIVE ACTION FROM THE
PRESIDENT CAN DO THAT.
AND IF CONGRESS AS IT APPEARS
LACKS THE VOTES TO DO THAT NOW,
VOTERS NEED TO MAKE THEIR VOICES
HEARD.
THIS FALL YOU MUST ELECT MORE
SENATORS AND REPRESENTATIVES WHO
WILL CODIFY A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE INTO FEDERAL LAW ONCE
AGAIN.
ELECT MORE STATE LEADERS TO
PROTECT THIS RIGHT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
WE NEED TO RESTORE THE
PROTECTIONS OF ROE AS LAW OF THE
LAND.
WE NEED TO ELECT OFFICIALS WHO
WILL DO THAT.
THIS FALL ROE IS ON THE BALLOT.
PERSONAL FREEDOMS ARE ON THE
BALLOT.
THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY, LIBERTY,
EQUALITY, THEY'RE ALL ON THE
BALLOT.
UNTIL THEN, I WILL DO ALL IN MY
POWER TO PROTECT A WOMAN'S RIGHT
IN STATES WHERE THEY WILL FACE
THE CONSEQUENCES OF TODAY'S
DECISION.
THE COURT'S DECISION CAST A DARK
SHADOW OVER A LARGE SWATH OF THE
LAND, MANY STATES IN THIS
COUNTRY STILL RECOGNIZE A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
SO A WOMAN LIVES IN A STATE THAT
RESTRICTS ABORTION, THE SUPREME
COURT'S DECISION DOES NOT
PREVENT HER FROM TRAVELING FROM
HER HOME STATE TO THE STATE THAT
ALLOWS IT.
IT DOES NOT PREVENT A DOCTOR IN
THAT STATE -- IN THAT STATE FROM
TREATING HER.
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS MADE
CLEAR, WOMEN MUST REMAIN FREE TO
TRAVEL SAFELY TO ANOTHER STATE
TO SEEK CARE THEY NEED.
MY ADMINISTRATION WILL DEFEND
THAT BEDROCK RIGHT.
IF ANY STATE OR LOCAL OFFICIAL
HIGH OR LOW TRIES TO INTERFERE
WITH A WOMAN'S EXERCISING HER
BASIC RIGHT TO TRAVEL, I WILL DO
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO FIGHT
THAT DEEPLY UN-AMERICAN ATTACK.
MY ADMINISTRATION WILL ALSO
PROTECT A WOMAN'S ACCESS TO
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE APPROVED BY
THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION, THE FDA LIKE
CONTRACEPTION, WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL FOR PREVENTIVE HEALTH
CARE.
THE FDA APPROVED OVER 20 YEARS
AGO TO SAFELY END EARLY
PREGNANCIES AND COMMONLY USED TO
TREAT MISCARRIAGES.
SOME STATES ARE SAY THAT THEY'LL
TRY TO BAN OR SUREARLY RESTRICT
ACCESS TO THESE MEDICATIONS.
BUT EXTREMIST GOVERNORS AND
STATE LEGISLATORS ARE LOOKING TO
BLOCK THE MAIL OR SEARCH A
PERSON'S MEDICINE CABINET OR
CONTROLLING A WOMAN'S ACTIONS ON
AN APP SHE USES ARE EXTREMELY
WRONG AND OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS.
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION, THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBTUTRITIONS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS WROTE STRESSING
THESE LAWS ARE NOT BASED ON
EVIDENCE AND ASKING US TO
PROTECT ACCESS TO CARE.
THEY SAY BY LIMITING ACCESS TO
THESE MEDICINES MATERNAL
MORTALITY WILL CLIMB IN AMERICA.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY.
TODAY I'M DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO TAKE STEPS TO ENSURE
THESE MEDICATIONS ARE AVAILABLE
TO THE FULLEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
AND THE POLITICIANS CANNOT
INTERFERE IN THE DECISIONS THAT
SHOULD BE MADE BETWEEN A WOMAN
AND HER DOCTOR.
AND MY ADMINISTRATION REMAINS
VIGILANT AS THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THIS DECISION PLAY OUT.
I'VE WARNED ABOUT HOW THIS
DECISION RISKS THE BROADER RIGHT
TO PRIVACY FOR EVERYONE.
THAT'S BECAUSE ROE RECOGNIZED
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
THAT HAS SERVED AS A BASIS FOR
SO MANY MORE RIGHTS THAT HAVE
COME TO TAKE -- WE'VE COME TO
TAKE FOR GRANTED, THAT ARE
INGRAINED IN THE FABRIC OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THE RIGHT TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISION FOR YOUR HEALTH, THE
RIGHT TO USE BIRTH CONTROL, A
MARRIED COUPLE IN THE PRIVACY OF
THEIR BEDROOM, FOR GOD'S SAKE.
THE RIGHT TO MARRY THE PERSON
YOU LOVE.
WHEN JUSTICE THOMAS SAID AS MUCH
TODAY.
HE EXPLICITLY CALLED TO
RECONSIDER THE RIGHT OF MARRIAGE
EQUALITY, THE RIGHT OF COUPLES
TO MAKE THEIR CHOICES ON
CONTRACEPTION.
THIS EXTREME AND DANGEROUS PATH
THE COURT IS NOW TAKING US ON.
LET ME CLOSE WITH TWO POINTS.
FIRST, I CALL ON EVERYONE NO
MATTER HOW DEEPLY THEY CARE
ABOUT THIS DECISION TO KEEP ALL
PROTESTS PEACEFUL.
PEACEFUL, PEACEFUL, PEACEFUL.
NO INTIMIDATION.
VIOLENCE IS NEVER ACCEPTABLE.
THREATS AND INTIMIDATION ARE NOT
SPEECH.
WE MUST STAND AGAINST VIOLENCE
IN ANY FORM REGARDLESS OF YOUR
RATIONALE.
SECOND, I KNOW SO MANY OF US ARE
FRUSTRATED AND DISILLUSIONED
THAT THE COURT HAS TAKEN
SOMETHING AWAY THAT'S SO
FUNDAMENTAL.
I KNOW SO MANY WOMEN ARE NOW
GOING TO FACE INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS.
I HEAR YOU, I SUPPORT YOU, I
STAND WITH YOU.
THE CONSEQUENCES AND THE
CONSENSUS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, CORE PRINCIPLES OF
EQUALITY, LIBERTY, DIGNITY AND A
STABILITY OF THE RULE OF LAW
DEMAND THAT ROE SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN OVERTURNED.
WITH THIS DECISION A
CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY OF THE
SUPREME COURT SHOWS HOW EXTREME
IT IS, HOW FAR REMOVED THEY ARE
FROM THE MAJORITY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
IT MADE THE UNITED STATES AN
OUTLIER AMONG DEVELOPED NATIONS
IN THE WORLD.
BUT THIS DECISION MUST NOT BE
THE FINAL WORD.
MY ADMINISTRATION WILL USE ALL
OF ITS APPROPRIATE LAWFUL
POWERS.
CONGRESS MUST ACT.
AND WITH YOUR VOTE, YOU CAN ACT.
YOU CAN HAVE THE FINAL WOR